merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche en son
absence je vais m'exprimer quand même
mon collègue alain suguenot l'a
interrogé la semaine dernière de façon
détaillée sur son bilan que dire de sa
réponse si ce n'est qu'elle a été plus
plus qu'évasif et surtout méprisante à
l'égard de la représentation nationale
et à travers elle
vis-à-vis des enseignants des parents et
des élèves
je vais l'a réitéré comme elle n'est pas
là je ne crains pas son courroux madame
la ministre ou le gouvernement monsieur
le premier ministre
avez vous enfin retrouvé l'évaluation
que vous deviez rendre publique
concernant la réforme des rythmes
scolaires mise en place il ya bientôt
deux ans vous la devez aux enseignants
aux maires des communes contraint de la
mettre en place aux parents et surtout
aux 7 millions d'écoliers le silence que
vous observez délibérément masque en
fait les effets néfastes de cette
réforme sur les finances des
collectivités tout d'abord sur
l'apprentissage des écoliers sur la
réorganisation du temps scolaire enfin
et surtout sur l'équité entre les élèves
puisqu'il y a des offres réellement
varier entre les territoires et surtout
varié en fonction des possibilités
contributive des parents si l'on ajoute
à cela le dénouement dramatique dans
lequel se trouvent nos lycées sur le
plan pédagogique les universités qui
sont les grandes oubliées de votre
gouvernement
ou bien la récente réforme du collège
qui est totalement incohérente
on mesure l'angoissent que la communauté
éducative et les parents partagent de la
maternelle au supérieur vous ne faites
aucune confiance aux enseignants
voulaient maintenait dans une pression
insupportable vous refuser le dialogue
et vous préférez les grands shows à la
cannoise comme celui des 2 et 3 mai
dernier dont le coût aurait bien plus
facilement trouver meilleure utilisation
madame la ministre monsieur le premier
ministre quand allez vous enfin faire
connaître les résultats de vos décisions
et de celles de vos prédécesseurs
merci la parole l'état me thierry mandon
secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci et monsieur le président madame
la députée votre question ou plutôt vos
questions concernent à la fois le bilan
d'évaluation de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires et d'une manière plus générale
la politique menée par le gouvernement
dans ce domaine sur la premier point
madame la ministre a déjà donné un
certain nombre d'éléments factuels que
je rappelle car ils sont importants pour
comprendre le travail systématique
d'évaluation que nous faisons de la mise
en place de l'importante réforme des
rythmes scolaires le rapport de la cnaf
publiée avec l'association des maires de
france en novembre dernier qui
confirmait la stabilité des coûts pour
les communes et le fait que grâce à
l'investissement des élus locaux cette
réforme avait été mis en place de
manière généralisée
le rapport préparé par la sénatrice
françoise cartron en octobre dernier sur
les activités périscolaires et sur les
améliorations à apporter pour les
communes rurales et enfin l'évaluation
du ministère qui est en travaux
actuellement pour des résultats dès
début 2010 est pour la seconde
donc conformément car est prévu pour la
seconde partie de votre question il est
exact que la priorité du gouvernement a
été de redonner à l'éducation nationale
les moyens que pendant cinq années vous
lui avez systématiquement enlevé c'est
80 mille postes que vous avez supprimé
et si j'en lis les programmes de vos
différents candidats aux primaires c'est
plus de cent mille postes que vous
préparez à enlever il est donc bien
normal que nous ayons fait un effort
budgétaire sans précédent pour remettre
l'éducation nationale à niveau et je
parie que ces résultats se verront dans
les prochains classements à ce sujet
merci la parole et à madame dominique
orliac